hey we had um we had some insanely long
live streams last week
because of the armed insurrection and we
got a great call
on our voicemail number which is 219 to
david p
uh just a very nice person saying thanks
for for the live streams thanks for the
long days take a listen
hi this message is for mr pacman this
is ambrosia i wanted to
just let you know that you did an
outstanding job yesterday january 6th
uh with your live streams you were
streaming for like six or seven
hours and um
it's crazy because your commentary made
sense you didn't wear out
you tapped out for a little bit and then
you came back i mean
it was better than any um mainstream
media news outlet
coverage that i saw i
got most if not all of my information
from your live stream so i just wanted
to say
you did an outstanding job you did
and my props to you and
lots of love from texas and we don't we
do not claim ted cruz we don't
okay thanks mr paxman all right there it
is a beautiful message i i really do
appreciate it we
we had uh yeah so on i mean on the sixth
as we watched what we thought would be a
very boring but long
many hours of debate over objections to
counting ballots we saw the armed
insurrection
uh grow before our very eyes
and they were very long days i really
appreciate hearing from folks who who
appreciated um
us us being with you and uh it was a
privilege
to be with everybody who joined those
streams and we're going to continue
covering
unfortunately i hate to say it but i
believe that there will be more to cover
in the next week and of course we will
be with you on january 20th for the
inauguration and swearing in
of president joseph r biden jr so much
much to come and of course the streams
are live
we're typically live on three platforms
youtube
which is youtube.com the david pakman
show twitch twitch.tv
davidpakman and facebookfacebook.com
davidpakmanshow so i will see you but
before that
uh we do have a great bonus show for you
today senator joe manchin
has a different view about stimulus
checks already it didn't take long my
friend so we will you know the idea of
is joe manchin going to be okay with
this it's not just a meme it's not just
a mere
hypothetical it immediately has an
impact we'll also talk about the biden
administration's
different approach on vaccine doses
really important topic
and we will also talk about a west
virginia republican state lawmaker
who has resigned after being allegedly
involved
in the riotous storming of the u.s
capitol so we will have
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show as i will be joined by
producer pat
you can sign up and get instant access
at
joinpakman.com